[Musica]
la terra il pianeta blu è ricoperta al
70 per cento di acqua
ma di questa solo il 2,5 per cento e
acqua dolce e solo l'uno per cento è
disponibile per consumi umani in italia
siamo ancora ricchi di acqua ma
rischiamo di diventare poveri perché il
nostro modello di utilizzo è basato
sull'abbondanza direi sullo spreco è un
modello intensivo di sfruttamento che
oggi ci rende vulnerabili
il nostro fabbisogno idrico è cresciuto
di 600 volte negli ultimi 100 anni e
rischia di raddoppiare entro la fine del
secolo sprechiamo acqua potabile per uso
in cui non è necessario e recuperiamo
poco più del 10 per cento dell'acqua
piovana
aumentano gli eventi climatici estremi
dovuti anche al cambiamento climatico e
sempre più spesso abbiamo vediamo
situazioni locali in cui l'acqua a
disposizione non è sufficiente a coprire
il fabbisogno cioè i momenti di grave
siccità e all'opposto assistiamo momenti
come ci sono fenomeni alluvionali tali
con piogge così forti che non permettono
all'acqua di defluire causando
gravissimi danni e purtroppo perdite di
vite umane
non possiamo più permetterci di
sottovalutare l'importanza dell'acqua e
la necessità di agire per preservarla ma
come possiamo stimolare questo principio
come possiamo essere chiamati ad agire
dobbiamo avere consapevolezza perciò è
necessario informare e sensibilizzare ed
è per questo che il fai ha lanciato una
campagna che si chiama salva l'acqua
indicando già cosa è necessario fare per
la tutela della risorsa idrica ovvero
promuovere il risparmio il recupero e il
riuso e mostrando anche come noi lo
facciamo concretamente nei nostri beni
infatti il fai che sono luoghi speciali
che il fai restaura recupera per
valorizzarli aprirvi alla fruizione di
tutti ti mostriamo come la bellezza
la cultura siano le radici profonde su
cui nasce e cresce la sostenibilità
ambientale
e così senza timore alcuno posso dire
che la campagna salva l'acqua nasce
dalla bellezza che cosa hanno in comune
la bellissima settecentesca villa panza
dove siamo e l'antichissimo giardino
della kolymbetra di agrigento
l'acqua o meglio il risparmio e recupero
dell'acqua nei beni del fai recuperiamo
molto spesso sistemi culturali
tradizionali traditional knowledge sono
quelle sistemi di sapienza antica frutto
della cultura popolare che si sono
creati nei secoli e nel nostro caso sono
sistemi che consentono di risparmiare e
recuperare l'acqua
partiamo adesso
la panza da qui quando il marchese
menafoglio individuo qui sul colle di
biumo il luogo dove creare la sua casa
di campagna a questo anche poco lontano
una cisterna d'acqua per la raccolta
piovana detta il vascone un enorme e
suggestivo spazio quadrangolare diviso
per 4 navate 6 campate con 15 colonne in
mattoni a vista capace di raccogliere
oltre un milione di litri di acqua e
ancora oggi in funzione porta l'acqua
alle fontane del parterre della villa ma
anche al laghetto che riesce a captare
300 metri cubi d'acqua che poi viene
utilizzata per irrigare il giardino in
sicilia se andiamo più lontano il fai e
custode di due beni come vi dicevo prima
che raccolgono questi antichi sistemi di
recupero dell'acqua il giardino della
kolymbetra di agrigento nella valle dei
templi nasce nel quinto secolo avanti
cristo una zona povera di acqua il
territorio agrigentino che ha fatto sì
che nascesse quest opera idraulica
straordinaria che oggi è testimoniata
ancora dagli acquedotti feaci sono
condotti scavati nella roccia quindi
canali ipogei creati per captare le
acque dalla collina dei dirigenti e
recuperare l'acqua lasciata dall umidità
della notte e poi portarla e per
permettere l'attività agricola l'acqua
raccolta anche con altri sistemi ci sono
antiche vasche dette jazz che riversano
poi l'acqua in canalini in terra battuta
e in canali di terracotta che permettono
poi di percorrere tutto il giardino
andando a irrigare gli orti un altro
bene il giardino pantesco nell'isola di
pantelleria ha donato dall'azienda
vitivinicola donnafugata è un altro
esempio di questo genere
in un'isola arssa e percossa dal vento
la sapienza antica ha creato un sistema
ingegnoso per permettere la coltivazione
degli agrumi
altrimenti impossibile il giardino
pantesco a una pianta circolare di 11
metri di diametro ed è cinta da un muro
a secco alto quattro metri
al suo interno custodisce una unica
pianta nel nostro caso una pianta di
portogallo un arancio dolce e questo
muro serve a proteggere la pianta non
solo dal vento ma anche a raccogliere
l'umidità della notte per far sì che
l'acqua arrivi al terreno e quindi non
sia necessario irrigarlo a partire dal
bello quindi ed al concreto abbiamo teso
un filo rosso che capace di riportarci a
una consapevolezza nei confronti della
risorsa idrica e quindi è nata la
campagna salva l'acqua il patto per
l'acqua
il libro blu
ma procediamo per
prima la campagna salva l'acqua la
campagna salva l'acqua nasce per
sensibilizzare tutti nel svolgere un
ruolo per il risparmio il recupero
dell'acqua un comportamento virtuoso che
abbiamo chiamato idro civismo
ma durante la campagna salva l'acqua nel
prepararla ci siamo resi conto che oltre
al comportamento individuale è
necessario per il paese
arrivare a formulare una vera strategia
nazionale per l'acqua innovativa capace
di farci uscire dagli stati di emergenza
ormai sempre più ricorrenti e che abbia
un modello di gestione efficiente e
sostenibile
per fare questo però ci siamo chiesti
come possiamo far sentire il bisogno di
questo al paese creando un accordo un
accordo sociale per l'acqua un blu dil
e così per fare questo abbiamo chiamato
intorno a uno stesso tavolo i principali
attori del sistema e farvi degli esempi
dagli enti di ricerca ai gestori delle
reti dai consorzi di bonifica agli
agricoltori dalle imprese a di
amministrazioni pubbliche dal terzo
settore
ma le associazioni di professionisti e
con questi a questo tavolo abbiamo
cercato i punti comuni condivisi per
portare il risultato di risparmiare per
riutilizzare l'acqua e questo patto è
fatto non solo di principi ma anche di
proposte concrete
il tavolo per patto dell'acqua adesso
sta lavorando al nostro libro bianco che
abbiamo chiamato libro blu e questo
vuole porre le basi per una vera
gestione integrata ed efficiente delle
acque nel paese che oggi diventa
strategica all'interno del piano
nazionale per la ripresa e la resilienza
legato al recovery fund e così iniziamo
ad agire oggi affinché nelle normative
di domani entrano sempre di più misure
con questo obiettivo ti risparmio e
recupero di acqua alcuni esempi di
queste proposte
non contenute nel patto per l'acqua per
esempio un pacchetto di misure che
riguarda l'implementazione del
monitoraggio dei consumi in tutti i
settori a partire dall uso maggiore di
tecnologie digitali conoscere quanto si
consuma è la base per avviare una
politica di efficientamento e poi
abbiamo immaginato il bisogno di creare
sempre di più incentivi fiscali affinché
poi ci siano e si acquistino e si
promuovano sistemi per il recupero delle
acque piovane e anche magari delle acque
grigie recuperare a monte l'acqua
piovana e molto importante non solo
perché ci permette di recuperare l'acqua
ma ci permette anche di mandare meno
scarico alla depurazione e inoltre è
importantissimo perché questo può
contenere i danni provocati dalle piogge
sempre violente che possono sempre di
più
ahimè incrementare nel nostro prossimo
futuro
cosa puoi fare tu per l'acqua
tu sei un cittadino idro civico solo per
darvi alcuni numeri che possiamo fissare
nella nostra testa un rubinetto aperto
consuma 12 litri al minuto 5 minuti di
doccia 60 litri e se scegliete il bagno
sono 110 litri il riduttori di getto che
possiamo montare a tutti i nostri
rubinetti riducono i consumi del 50 per
cento
la manutenzione degli impianti idraulici
e molto importante la classica goccia
che perde dal rubinetto ogni due secondi
ci fa perdere 6 mila litri di acqua
all'anno per raccogliere quell acqua
piovana possiamo utilizzare anche dei
semplici contenitori oppure a chiedere
al nostro condominio di installare una
cisterna puoi chiedere al tuo comune di
creare dei rentheart per raccogliere le
acque piovane
oppure puoi pensare a un tetto verde per
la tua abitazione e soprattutto
ricordarti di non inquinare l'acqua
facendo attenzione a quello che lasci
nello scarico
dobbiamo agire dobbiamo reagire
i cambiamenti climatici sono un'evidenza
non permettiamo che anche la crisi
idrica lo diventi dobbiamo agire per
innovare creare progettare le soluzioni
per il futuro
l'innovazione per il risparmio
dell'acqua per il recupero dell'acqua
sono fondamentali
puoi farlo anche tu a partire dall
attività che svolge dal settore in cui
lavori lasciamoci ispirare dalla storia
dalla cultura materiale raccontata nei
nostri bellissimi paesaggi dobbiamo
essere curiosi avere il desiderio di
conoscere e approfondire quello che la
cultura e la storia sanno raccontarci ma
soprattutto avere il coraggio di
progettare il nostro futuro garantendo
al paese uno sviluppo sostenibile e
inclusivo e capace di generare
nuovamente bellezza
[Musica]